il faut savoir que l'administrateur de
la commune france elle est nommée par le
gouvernement est pour l'instant bien et
c'est super attendre dans quelques jours
la comédie française connaîtra soumis à
l'administrateur en attendant celui ci
comment réagit-on du côté du palais
royal compris avec cody sans connotation
est le seul qui joue trois salles
différentes et aux salariés comme
ailleurs le club grosse machine qui
demandent outre des qualités des
aptitudes de la diplomatie
donc il faut la purée parce que 3,7 à
ses concédants qu'il n'ait pas réussi
je crois qu'il faut pas peur ni par
chacun de nous le successeur de jean le
premier instrument donc une rup décider
du répertoire et a fait la coupe en
famille sans de nouveaux sociétaires
calmer les aigreurs provoquées par les
dernières nominations la tête de la
maison et surtout préserver le prestige
du premier démocrate